hi my name is Mark heads from the mkbhd
channel if someone sent you this video
it means they know you're a tech
enthusiast and that you can probably
relate to this stuff or you may have
done some of these things but hopefully
not there are a few things that can get
on the nerves of people like us so on
behalf of a lot of other youtubers and
the tech community I have a few requests
for the fanboys and the newbies out
there here we go
stop asking simple questions before you
try to google the answer you can stop
checking in to your own house now on
Foursquare stop asking for a
recommendation between blackberries
because we can't tell them apart stop
using Internet Explorer seriously
seriously it is for your own good and
stop judging people based on what kind
of phone they carry on Facebook stop
asking people to like your profile
picture it's terrifying and stop talking
about tumblr outside of tumblr oh you
ever see some guy on a bus or train some
more public just having a ridiculously
loud conversation on their bluetooth
headphone don't be that guy
stop asking if every tablet in existence
is an iPad this is not an iPad stop
comparing every thin laptop to the
MacBook Air and Apple stop suing every
company that makes a phone with a
touchscreen please and if you could
please stop reporting on rumors of the
next iPhone every freaking day and
please please stop asking us to fix
everything that breaks just because
we're geeks and stop using MySpace
stop it
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video give it a
thumbs up below I really do appreciate
it and if you have any more feedback or
other things that you hate you know you
can leave that in a comment below as
well thanks for watching this video and
thanks for subscribing case